first congrats the first three episodes
are so cool
can't wait to see where it's going um
i'm curious when you actually booked the
role
and you land the part how much are you
actually
told about the arc of the character in
juan division and captain marvel 2
and how much is it sort of like i just
trust marvel
when i actually first booked it i didn't
know i didn't even know the character
there's that you know marvel's very top
secret then once i found out the
character i didn't know what was
happening with this character for a
couple of months
so it it almost felt like this is not
real i'm i did not really get cast in an
mcu movie because it's all so hush-hush
there was no press release there i
couldn't tell anybody
and they hadn't really said anything so
i didn't quite believe that it was true
and then once we got into it we talked
about the entire arc of
um monica during the series of one
division which essentially serves as her
origin
story in the mcu and um i didn't really
we don't really get into um what's to
come
but it was announced that she would be
in captain marvel too so that's really
exciting and i'm i'm
looking forward to how she will evolve
further into the mcu completely um
it's uh how have you been able to
describe your character to people i
normally don't ask that
but we only really get a tease in the
first three episodes
of who you are i've
described monica as
wanda's neighbor
got it i got it i think after people see
uh episode three they might think other
things okay and i can't wait for them to
think those things
and yeah but actually talk about them
completely
one of the things i think that's really
cool about wand division is that it's a
really big swing for marvel
it is not um it is unlike anything
in the mcu it's completely different um
can you sort of talk about like the risk
like the risks they're taking with this
series yeah i mean
you know you say it's a risk but i guess
being in it it just feels like it just
makes such total sense because i see
what it is like the care the attention
the passion the detail that has gone
into making each of these episodes yes a
sitcom
but also this very epic marvel
production um so and and then for us to
be the
marvel's debut into television uh with
disney plus
it makes sense this this correlation
between one division which is a show
that pays homage to american television
over the decades and so
it's it's been really cool i i they are
swinging for the fence
and i think that it will uh they'll be
rewarded with the excitement
and the um the um
all the fanfare i think the fans are
gonna love it i hope
yeah i um okay as i said i can't wait to
watch more uh so hopefully
you can actually answer this because we
know you're in captain marvel too
uh do you know when you actually start
filming and have you
heard anything about like the the script
and the story
no no and no and that's not even a lie
like no got it um well then i'll ask you
this question
uh one of the things about wand division
is that you guys shot a bunch
and then you got shut down because of
covid and then you came back
um can you sort of talk about what you
filmed before the covid hiatus
and then what you filmed after and how
maybe covet impacted the production well
it was
actually a planned hiatus because we are
shoot we shot some in atlanta
and then we were going to la so it crazy
enough
once we finally wrapped in atlanta which
was a whole other saga between the
weather
and all we really care when y'all see
this please no we have put so much
into this even before cobit like all the
things that could happen have happened
during this shoot but more on that later
um so it was a planned hiatus and then
once we went down like a few days into
it the
the world i mean the us pretty much shut
down and so then it was
an extended uh hiatus
i don't know what oh i know in l.a i was
like i don't know what we shot but in
l.a
we shot a lot of the sitcom stuff
because obviously the
stages and blondie street that's all out
there so
um we were able to use those facilities
on that note i gotta go thank you so
much for your time can't wait to see the
rest
all right bye